コメント欄で校調に発達障害について話して欲しいっていうのがたくさんあったので、
今回それについて伺いたいです。
うん。よわからんのだ。発達障害っていうのが。だけど全然文科家に聞いてみたんよ。発達障害って何ですか?精神病だっていうの発達障害はね。
だったらば今発達障害及びその周辺という
発達障害かどうかなというタイプの子供が
子供全体の6割をおるっていうんやで。
日本はきの国や。6割が発達障害来た
おかしいやろ。そんなことはありえない。
だから発達障害と似た症状発達障害もきが
教育によってできたと考える方がええ。
本部省あるいはマスコミというのはもう
おそらく分かっとるやろ。自分たちが
間違っとったから教育がおかしくなったん
や。その証拠として発達障害ができたんや
。きがだったら自分たちの責任を問われる
といかもんであれは元々精神病だったんだ
ということにしときゃええということや
ないかね。発達障害と言われても一ぺ
ハトナをつけてなんとかして発達障害もき
から脱出させる方法を考えた方がその子の
一緒にとってはいいんじゃない?
だからみんなグレーゾーンなんやと思うよ
。私障害みたいに見える。例えばね、よく
問題になっとんのは何?神経症や。神経症
と精神病ね。いわゆる分裂症どこが違うん
や。うちでやってみると分裂症は治らんよ
。必質障害だ。だけどいわゆる神経症と
いうのは治るよ。機能障害なんだ。だから
機能を増大させる。機能が低下しとるから
神経症という症状が出とるんであって機能
を増大させると正常にすると神経症が
なくなっちゃう。だから機能障害ない。
同じように発達障害と言われてるのも必質
障害と機能障害のおそらく両方があるんだ
。
そうしないとあの人数の多さっていうのは分かり知れへんやろ。
最近だと、ま、自閉症アスペルガーって呼ばれるものとかあとは
ADHD
注意血管多政治とかがま、増えてるみたいですね。
うん。うん。ね、あいつはもう誰がそうするかうちの孫ぐの時多しようと言われとったよ。だけど小学校に入る中学校に入ったら学校で表彰されるぐらいまでになっとったよ。いい人です。
[音楽]
言って教育の成果が現れたなんて言い
やがってな。たが当たり前やないか。
小さい子というのは小さい子がシューンと
しとったらおかしくないだけだけどもそう
やって動き回る先生の言いこと悲観医者の
言うことも悲観というのが多症おかしいと
されちまうというこれはおかしいよね。
大人の発達障害っていう、ま、その落ち着きのなさが大人になっても出てる人も増えてるって言われてるんですけど、
進歩しなければそのままになっちゃうんじゃないの。で、それで認められちまったらしょうがないやろ。脳さんでもええ、おそらくその状態が楽なんやろうね。本人にとってでそれでよろしいと言われたらそのままおるよね。こ直せ言われたら直すよりしょうがないけどね。
[音楽]
番いいかんのは達と言われたらば生きていけるということやね。
就職なんかせんでもこれはおかしいんだ
から障害なんだから障害者なんだから年金
あげましょうというそれをもらうために
もう小さい頃ね障害のあれをもらいたがる
んや親がよ
昭和とかでも落ち着きのない性とか
まおっちょこちょいの大人とかもう
これを発達障害にはあんま言われてなかっ
たんですかねそんなことないの昔はな、
みんな個人の責任にされたやろ。お前が
おかしいと言われて、ちゃんとしろ言われ
ておかしいやつでも少しずつこう直してっ
たわけやね。いいやけど、
安間まで以前校調が落ちこぼれのことを発達障害っていうくりにしてしまってるみたいな発言をされてて、ちょっとスタジオがざわざわしてたと思うんですけど、これのシーンも伺かってもいいですか?
なんかあれはリベラルの言葉がりや。そういう症状あるいは状態を言っとるんであって何も正確に病を言っとるわけやないやろ。いいじゃない。それをこれはこういう落ちこぼれ。これは発達障害。
これはどうのって言ったらそれがうなるんか。そやないやろ。で言うと発達障害も明確に定義できるものではない病気なんですけど
[音楽]
うん。
ちょっと曖昧性が高いですね。ちょっと曖昧性が高すぎるんじゃない?だからむしろちゃんと教育をしてみて何ともならんやつだけをあれにしたらええんや。
それをちゃんと教育もせずにおいてな、もうめんどくさいやつはみんな発達障害にしとるというのが今の状態じゃない。
校長的にはどういう風な定義だったら納得感がありそうですかね?
いや、分からんよ。それは専門家の決めることであってね、おそらく進歩の能力が全くないやつやろうと思う。発達障害っていうのはね、発達の障害やもんね。発達でおそらく進歩のことやろ。
それが障害されとるんだから、その新父の能力がないという風に考えるべきやないかなと思うんやけどね。
以前の動画から校長は結構精神会についてあんまりよく思ってない感じなんですかね。
精神会だからさっき言ったように何にも知らんし何にもできないのが精神会だと言われるという前ね教育じゃなしにただのヨッスクールをやっとる時に時々精会の先生が来とったんだ。邪魔しかせんのだ。
その教室にやってきてさ、その教室の邪魔
をするんよ。だからあなた金払ったんだ
からちゃんとやったらどうですかって言っ
たるんや。そ、私はやる時はちゃんとやる
。見事にやってのけるんです。今はそう
じゃないから。なんで金払ってなんであれ
したのよ。で、説明しとるとその邪魔を
するんやな。人が先生になるのが気に
食わんのやな。おかしな人なんやで。パッ
と立ち上がって、もうこの辺でやめにして
そろそろお茶にしましょうとか言う。授業
の邪魔するわけな。他の生徒が怒っちゃっ
てさ、彼家の先生と言っとるけど患者さん
じゃないんですか?て言い出すんや。
こんな人ばっかりと会っとるもんでな。
精神会としてはどうして精神会になったの
?あとは自分が少しおかしかったからじゃ
ないの言って言ったら起こるけどな。
最後にこの動画見てる方の中で発達障害グレーゾーンわゆるま、典型的なのではないけどちょっとそういう症状があるんじゃないかって思ってる方も多いと思うのでその方たちにメッセージだけないでしょうか?
えっとですね、精神病を見てるとあれは本能が狂るっとるな。精神病の人見ると理性の問題はないわ。だから発達障害のもおそらく本能になんか結果があるかもしれない。
だから申しが言うように当然の木を養う。
あれをやってみたらうまくいくかもしれん
よ。あいつは本能を完璧にしようという
方法やからね。
申し読んだら中に書いてあるからこうしたらええっていうのが一ぺ自分で読めとやってみる価値はあるから一生そんな状態で国の世話になって生きていってあんた満足できるのかなもできへんのやから
進歩の能力はあるんだけど発達障害って言われてるまもしくはそうじゃないかって思ってる人に対してはどうですか?
何を持って進歩の能力というかよね今みたいに偏差はダめやであれは物を覚えとるだけで進歩しとるわけやないんよね。
だから本当の進歩。進歩ってどういうことが分かる?
価値を獲得すること。
自分の価値を上げることやね。これが進歩なんだ。で、その時にちゃんと進歩したかどうかっていうのはこれも申し読むと分かるわ。自分で分かる。なぜならば進歩したらこう立弁に兼ねるね。こうって読む。こうという状態になるからこうというのは感が発生する幸せになる。
人間
進歩したら必ず幸せになるから。もし自分がなんかをやって幸せになったらそのことについて進歩したという証拠である。それて確かめてみろよ。だから偏差修はダメやろ。あれは進歩と言わんね。だから価値が上がったとは言えない。
[音楽]
[笑い]
進歩の能力があるけどやっぱ地外が言って思っちゃってる人とかそう診断された人とかはそのまま頑張ればいいっていうですか?
うん。そのまま頑張って進歩すりゃええじゃん。何の問題も起こらへんやろ。
だから周りが何と言うとそれがどうしたってま言えるだけの能力があればええんやけどね。強くないとそれは言えんだやけど強くなりゃええ。進歩したことを強くなったという。
ありがとうございます。
[音楽]